un rideau à câlins pour retrouver le
contact avec ses proches
alors que le brésil est toujours ravagé
par l'épidémie de kovy 19
c'est une innovation simple mais
efficace que bruno annie a décidé de
commercialiser
l'idée est venue d'un documentaire
intitulé un câlin de trois minutes sur
une action menée par une ong à la
frontière entre les etats-unis et le
mexique
le principe est simple enfilez des
manches de protection sur ses bras avant
de les glisser dans des ouvertures
prévues à cet effet pour pouvoir
simplement lassé ses proches j'aime
vraiment la vie je laime vraiment mais
si ce n'était pas pour ma famille et
pour dieu je ne pense pas que je
voudrais vraiment continuer à vivre
un soulagement pour les résidents mais
aussi pour leurs familles c'est une
excellente façon de combler ce manque
je pense que c'était bon pour l est
aussi pour nous parce que nous ne serons
personnes dans nos bras ces derniers
temps n'est ce pas c'était donc génial
d'étreindre quelqu'un
du côté du personnel soignant ce
dispositif arrive à point nommé pour
rassurer les résidents et leur permettre
de retrouver un lien affectif et
physique avec leurs proches
alors que nous réalisons à présent que
la pandémie va durer beaucoup plus
longtemps que prévu
nous devons trouver des moyens sûrs afin
de permettre à ces familles de voir
leurs proches qui sont ici est que ces
personnes âgées puissent accueillir
leurs familles et comprendre qu'elles
sont toujours inquiète
hélas pour elle
un contact physique qui manque à tous
est d'autant plus lorsque l'on est en
maison de retraite
isolé de sa famille